[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes de débats de
reportage et d'analyse 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et voici le sommaire de ce 26
septembre Julien Bayou démissionne de
son poste de secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts c'est Kafka
à l'heure des réseaux sociaux dit le
député de Paris son avocate a rappelé
l'absurdité de sa situation cet
après-midi
Julien Bayou a quitté ses fonctions du
parti écologiste et démissionné de la
présidente du groupe à l'Assemblée pour
pouvoir se défendre en toute liberté
contre des accusations dont il ignore
tout et contre les ragots rumeurs et
autres mensonges qui gangrène notre vie
démocratique
cette histoire market-telle l'échec des
cellules d'écoute contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles au sein des partis
politiques on en débattra tout à l'heure
c'est une très nette victoire pour
Georgia Meloni et ses alliés de droite
et l'extrême droite en Italie quels
seront ses premières réformes la future
présidente du conseil des ministres
va-t-elle calmer le jeu avec l'Union
européenne alors que son pays est l'un
des plus endetté du continent ne ratez
pas l'analyse de nos experts dans 45
minutes mais d'abord l'autre actualité
politique de ce lundi c'est la
présentation du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
conseil des ministres ce matin pas
d'amendement sur l'allongement de l'âge
de la retraite pour l'instant la
question de la méthode n'est pas encore
tranchée par l'exécutif Jérôme Rabier
les impatients en seront pour leur frais
on ne sait pas encore si le gouvernement
compte réformer les retraites des 7
automne mais cela ne devrait plus tarder
comme la confirmer ce matin la première
ministre on en parle cette semaine avec
les responsables de la majorité et on
fera part de la décision que nous
prendrons avec le président de la
République d'ici la fin de la semaine
pourquoi d'ici la fin de la semaine et
pourquoi pas la semaine qu'on cherche la
meilleure voie pour je vous dis à la
fois mettre en œuvre cette réforme
rapidement à l'été 2023 en même temps
avoir laissé la place au dialogue
mercredi soir aura donc lieu un dîner au
sommet réunissant exécutif et chef de la
majorité avant une décision vendredi en
attendant le gouvernement reste sur un
an même temps tout macronien nous
mettrons également en œuvre une réforme
des retraites
pourront le faire de manière juste un
rythme raisonnable en garantissant
l'efficacité de cette réforme qui doit
permettre de financer notre modèle de
protection sociale si le gouvernement ne
veut pas abattre ses cartes en ce début
de semaine les opposants sont déjà prêts
y compris la CFDT le fer en
rapides rapidement l'ouzé d'une certaine
manière dans un amendement pfss c'est
inacceptable pour la CFDT on a besoin
d'un vrai sujet un vrai débat le choix
éventuel du gouvernement de passer par
un amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
même dénoncés par des alliés du
président comme François Bayrou du modem
sans majorité sur le sujet le
gouvernement devrait alors user du
fameux article 49-3 pour le faire passer
ce qui ne devrait pas faire baisser
l'attention au Parlement comme dans la
rue pour un projet de réforme ardemment
défendu par le chef de l'État
et pour débattre d'abord de cette
réforme des retraites la méthode et le
fond je vous présente mes invités
Anne-Sophie elsif bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chef économiste du cabinet de
conseil BDO France Pablo piovillien
bonsoir et bienvenue rédacteur en chef
de la revue regard Éric Delannoy bonsoir
bienvenue économiste et président
fondateur de Tenzin conseil et Mathieu
croissanto éditorialise politique
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous aussi
alors on vient de le voir la décision
d'être surprises sur la la méthode
Anne-Sophie elle se fait est-ce que vous
seriez surprise quand même on va parler
du fond après mais que Kemal Macron
choisissent le passage en force malgré
il y en a eu plusieurs toutes les mises
en garde notamment de venus de son
propre camp alors c'est vrai que la
dernière fois c'était possible puisqu'on
avait vu la première législature que ils
avaient essayé de le mettre en force
avant la crise covid là c'est vrai qu'il
y a plus la majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée donc ça change énormément
à mon sens l'idée ça va quand même être
avoir un consensus avec les partenaires
avant de passer en force parce que ce
serait peut-être la dernière échéance
avant mais c'est vrai que politiquement
je pense qu'il perdrait beaucoup de
points notamment par rapport à toutes
les mesures pour pouvoir d'achat qui
vont sûrement avoir lu l'année prochaine
donc il lui faudra une majorité il lui
faudra avoir du soutien grillé toutes
ces cartouches maintenant ça paraît peu
probable Pablo Piot Vivien est-ce que ça
changera quelque chose est-ce que ça
changerait quelque chose à la
mobilisation
syndicale notamment ceux qui sont
opposés à une réforme des retraites
est-ce que qu'on passe en force ou pas
de toute façon il descendront dans la
rue d'ailleurs ils vont déjà descendre
une première fois cette semaine
peu importe la méthode qu'elle soit
brutale par le passage via le PLFSS ou
que ça soit dans le cadre d'une pas en
fait d'un projet de loi normal avec un
grand débat au Parlement etc dans les
deux cas en fait vous vous avez
potentiellement en fait des
mobilisations notamment sociales c'est
juste qu'elles seront pas tout à fait du
même ordre vous pensez que ça donne
quand même un amendement dans le PLFSS
il y a beaucoup moins de débats ça passe
beaucoup plus rapidement c'est des
battues en l'espace de en fait de
quelques j'allais dire de quelques
minutes enfin un amendement ça peut être
très très rapide contrairement à un
projet de loi où il y a un passage en
commission et la navette etc et tout
prend du temps donc mais après le
problème c'est que si il passe par un
amendement dans le PLFSS alors comme ça
a été dit par Laurent Berger tout à
l'heure mais c'est aussi on sait que la
CGT est absolument sur la même ligne et
que globalement même au sein de sa
propre majorité ça commence à dire il y
a le Bron Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale elle est pas elle
a pas l'air hyper enchantée par le fait
que ça soit assez clair elle a été elle
a été envoyée également exactement donc
vous avez une foultitude en fait de
petits éléments qui font que si jamais
ils assument en fait ce passage via le
PLFSS ils vont se prendre dans la dans
la figure et quelque chose d'assez
violent après ils peuvent le faire un
potentiellement c'est quelque chose qui
fait partie en fait des cartes qui
peuvent abattre à abattre sur la table
parce que ça ça voudra aussi dire de la
part du gouvernement voilà nous on est
on assume en fait notre réformisme parce
que c'est ce qu'il répète à l'envie ils
l'ont répété énormément pendant la
campagne présidentielle et pendant les
campagnes législatives on assume notre
réforme et la réforme ça passe aussi par
bousculer un peu les institutions
montrer que Emmanuel Macron même dans un
second mandat un faibli par l'absence de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée peut
continuer de réformer est-ce que vous
diriez Delannoy je suis toujours sur la
méthode que l'utilisation d'un
amendement au sein du projet de
financement la sécurité sociale ce
serait même une erreur politique est-ce
que vous allez jusque là qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez oui ce serait une erreur
politique mais je crois pas qu'on ira
jusque là je pense que moi qu'on est sur
une discussion de la méthode avant avant
le fond pour inviter les différents
acteurs à se mettre autour de la table
parce que faut quand même voir d'où on
vient on vient d'une situation pendant
un an et demi on a parlé des réformes de
retraite ça s'est achevé par le covid et
que on a en face de nous quand je dis en
face de nous le gouvernement en face de
lui tes oppositions qui proposent pas
grand chose si ce n'est de dire non non
c'est non donc pour faire pour qu'il y
ait dialogue il faut être deux donc pour
être deux il faut inviter les uns les
autres à venir autour de la table
comment on invite les uns les autres à
venir autour la table on les menace
d'avoir recours à une méthode brutale
s'ils ne viennent pas pour d'un seul
coup paraître
ouvert et prêts à la discussion Laurent
Berger a raison de dire que ça peut pas
se faire en trois minutes et par un
petit amendement il a raison simplement
il faut venir avec des propositions
avez-vous entendu beaucoup de
propositions alternatives par rapport à
une réforme qui a été annoncée il y a 5
ans qui a été conduite pendant deux ans
et qui a été réannoncé au moment de
l'élection présidentielle il y a pas
beaucoup de propositions sinon de dire
non avec quelquefois d'ailleurs des
arguments juste hallucinants un de dire
quarante années de cotisations pour des
gens qui a quand même eu dans la
première tentative de réforme il y a eu
des débats longs et tout le monde
s'exprimer les syndicats y compris oui
des ballons même et enfin on est passé
je vous rappelle d'une réforme
structurelle à une réforme paramétrique
on va y revenir donc on a changé de
paradigme donc là ce qui serait façon
c'est de revenir sur qu'est-ce qu'on
veut faire en fait sur le fond de
rouille on va revenir sur le fond il me
semble important mais il me semble que
commencer par la forme c'était pour moi
une tactique politique pour dire on a
besoin de dialogue on a besoin de gens
autour de la table alors on a entendu
mais en version courte on va dire ça
comme ça Laurent Berger dans dans le
sujet d'ouverture de de ce débat et
comme on en parle les uns les autres je
vous propose de l'écouter un peu plus
longuement donc c'était ce matin sur sur
Europe 1 il y a effectivement cette
petite phrase sur attention à ne pas
passer en loose d le sujet des retraites
c'est pas qu'un sujet budgétaire c'est
un sujet social de qui allier qui a lieu
un lien avec le travail un sujet
sociétal ce qu'on veut faire dans notre
société le faire en rapide rapidement
l'ouzed d'une certaine manière dans un
amendement pfss c'est inacceptable pour
la CFDT on a besoin d'un vrai sujet un
vrai débat
la CFDT si on fait un tout petit peu
d'histoire politique et social c'est
souvent le syndicat sur lequel les
gouvernements sont appuyés pour faire
passer des réformes donc braquer Laurent
Berger c'est quand même très dangereux
oui parce que là il y a un petit peu
l'idée que il y a l'inflation il y a la
crise énergétique donc il y a un peu
beaucoup beaucoup d'incertitude et puis
commencer que c'est une réforme
difficile on pourra en profiter et faire
passer ça un petit peu comme ça comme si
de rien n'était en fait alors qu'en
effet la réforme des retraites c'est
quand même une réforme qui comme il a
dit n'est pas que économique qui est
aussi très politique qui concerne
absolument tous les Français et donc je
crois qu'il y a vraiment une méfiance
alors bien évidemment au niveau du
Parlement mais aussi au niveau des
syndicats en disant même par rapport à
leurs adhérents bah voilà on va en fait
accepter un package vu le contexte et
puis derrière ben finalement on va faire
passer peut-être des choses qui peuvent
changer ou avoir des impacts assez
importants est-ce que Mathieu est pas un
petit peu en train de tomber dans un
dans un petit piège médiatique c'est à
dire que
beaucoup de mousse autour de attention
on va peut-être passer par le PLFSS et
puis non parce que c'est une option qui
est quand même envisagée alors après il
y a toujours en politique l'idée d'un
ballon d'essai et puis ça ça se dégonfle
et après on dit bien voyez je suis pas
si méchant en fait ça va bien se passer
un peu comme chez le dentiste ça va
faire très mal en fait j'avais pas mal
mais là on est pas quand même là-dedans
parce que c'est une option qui envisagé
si on raisonne d'un point de vue
purement d'opportunité politique
j'allais dire cynique de l'intérêt
personnel il y a tous les risques qui a
très bien
décrit tout à l'heure mais sur sur le
sur l'opportunité politique pour pour
Emmanuel Macron il peut se dire une
chose c'est que de toute façon
il s'agit de bouger des paramètres donc
ça peut se faire dans un amendement
puisqu'on en gros les seuls les seuls
paramètres qu'on va bouger c'est soit la
durée de cotisation soit là je légale de
départ en retraite il peut juger que il
y a pas de bons moments pour faire ça
que quand on regarde sur le temps non
chaque gouvernement depuis 20 ans prend
un petit peu sa part la dernière fois
c'était un Marisol Touraine sous
François Hollande avance était François
Fillon ou Nicolas Sarkozy enfin voilà
chacun prend un petit peu et puis avant
on peut remonter soit enfin il y en
avait eu aussi chacun prend un petit peu
sa part sur la durée de cotisation et
puis se dire le 49-3 bah de toute façon
il est gratuit on sait qu'on sait que
c'est limite et l'usage de 49 vous
pouvez l'utiliser j'allais dire
gratuitement c'est à dire sans manger au
crédits pour le budget donc le budget
est obligé de la sécurité sociale en
revanche une fois pour les budget et une
fois pour le budget pour un autre texte
si vous le faites pour un autre texte
vous avez droit qu'à une fois par an
donc il peut se dire comme ça je fais
d'une pierre deux coups je ne je ne
n'utilise pas mon crédit 49-3 et je le
fais là et puis surtout le raisonnement
qui tienne c'est il y a pas de bons
moments au début de l'année prochaine
les gens vont recevoir leurs factures
d'énergie ils vont voir que ça augmente
ils sont mauvaise humeur ils seront
d'eau autant de mauvaise humeur qu'avant
et puis dernière chose les partenaires
sociaux ne bougeront pas c'est vrai
Laurent Berger a toujours enfin la CFDT
a toujours accompagné des réformes des
retraites mais avec des mesures
complémentaires donc c'était on accepte
la hausse mais en tenant compte des
carrières longues de la pénibilité des
choses comme ça là si la réforme est
purement paramétrique on voit bien que
le pouvoir commencer par ça après juste
et j'en termine c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qu'on peut pas faire sur un coin
de table parce que précisément augmenter
la durée de cotisation repousser l'âge
légal ça pose des problèmes à toute une
catégorie de gens toute une série de
gens qui ont des carrières morcelées qui
ont soit commencé très jeune qui voilà
et qu'on vit des maladies enfin il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'événements dans
une carrière et ces gens-là on
s'interroge légitimement qu'est-ce
qu'elle dispositif votre conçu pour eux
on peut pas leur dire on joue les
leviers d'abord et puis on verra après
ça se passe ça marche pas comme ça mais
réunir tout le monde de la table autour
de la table pour arriver à un consensus
moi j'y crois pas du tout en deux mois
en trois mois en 6 mois en un an ou deux
ans ça marchera pas le 49 3 vous l'avez
évoqué la première ministre Elisabeth
borne qui était ce matin l'invité de nos
confrères de BFM TV on l'écoute
moi je vais vous dire ma méthode c'est
le dialogue la recherche de compromis en
même temps je pense que les Français ne
comprendraient pas qu'on soit bloqué
c'est vrai sur le budget c'est vrai sur
les réformes importantes qu'on veut
porter donc c'est un des outils qui est
à la disposition du gouvernement si on
constate une situation de blocage la
priorité pour moi c'est le dialogue la
concertation la recherche de compromis
le blocage ne viendra pas de ma part
alors janvier au fond maintenant Pablo
piovia est-ce que pour vous cette
réforme des retraites elle est urgente
si je il y a une grosse bataille en fait
pour estimer le caractère urgent de
cette de cette réforme ou de cette
contre-réforme comme on dit à gauche des
retraites sur en fait les conclusions du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites et
notamment de son dernier rapport qui est
sorti il y a pas longtemps
en vérité il y a un débat en fait pour
savoir si est-ce que le corps en gros
nous dit que les perspectives en du
système vont être déficitaires de
manière chronique et qu'au bout d'un
moment tout va partir à volo ou est-ce
que finalement le le taux d'endettement
du système ça va pouvoir tenir encore
quelques années quelques dizaines
d'années voir voir tout le temps
là-dessus vous avez le gouvernement qui
dit à mes regarder parce qu'en gros une
des conditions du corps c'est de dire
voilà dans les en 2021 et en 2022 le
système le oui le système est
excédentaire et puis après pendant 10
ans il va être déficitaire et puis
ensuite bon là ça devient un peu plus
flou on sait pas trop ils disent qu'il
va revenir à l'équilibre mais on sait
pas trop c'est en 2030 chacun peut
trouver un peu ce qu'il veut dans le
dans ta merde dans la synthèse que je
conseille à tout le monde de lire parce
qu'elle est elle est relativement courte
il y a cette phrase qui dit les
résultats de ce rapport ne valide pas le
bien-fondé des discours qui mettent en
avant l'idée d'une dynamique non
contrôlée des dépenses de retraite je
vous dis ça c'est ce qui m'intéresse
puisque je suis de gauche et que je ne
pense que c'est pas urgent et c'est
d'autant moins urgent que il y a
énormément d'autres urgences en fait sur
la table a commencé par l'urgence
écologique on est dans une période de
crise intense avec des guerres avec
énormément de stress une crise
énergétique qui va faire que cet hiver
il y a sûrement des gens qui vont pas
réussir à chauffer qui vont pas réussir
à remplir leur frigidaire etc donc si
vous mettez tout ça bout à bout on se
dit mais que pourquoi est-ce que il y a
une urgence à faire passer cette réforme
merci Pablo je pense je suis pas sûr que
nos deux économies soient sur la même
ligne Anne-Sophie elle si il faut
recommencer et ensuite Erica il y a
plusieurs sujets en effet pour pour le
corps lorsqu'ils font ces prévisions ils
utilisent beaucoup d'indicateurs dont la
croissance dans des gains de
productivité dont le taux de chômage
donc des indicateurs qui peuvent
beaucoup changer en fonction de la
situation macroéconomique on l'a vu avec
le covid l'argument pourquoi faire ça
parce que là il y a beaucoup de crises
avant vous allez me dire il y a la crise
sanitaire avant il y avait la crise
financière avant il avait la crise qui
commerciale entre la Chine les
États-Unis donc ça c'est il y a jamais
de moments pour faire cette réforme le
sujet à mon sens c'est pas l'âge de
départ c'est le niveau des pensions on
voit déjà que l'âge de départ effectif
c'est déjà 64 ans les gens continuent de
travailler pour avoir une pension plus
élevée et en fait ce qu'on regarde le
corps il faudrait le prolonger moi je
pense qu'il faudrait le prolonger alors
pourquoi en effet c'est pas demain
après-demain qu'il va y avoir un
problème de son habilité etc parce que
il y a d'autres problèmes de
soutenabilité par ailleurs donc c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est à moyen
long terme c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
un débat de société quelle place on veut
donner en terme de pouvoir d'achat et de
capacité financière assez catégories il
y a deux éléments le fait de dépasser de
décaler l'âge de départ par exemple à 65
ou 67 ans dans d'autres pays ça permet
d'augmenter le taux d'emploi des seniors
donc d'avoir plus d'obactivité chez les
plus de 55 ans si en effet les
entreprises jouent le jeu mais on voit
que dans les
hypocrisie monstrueuse
quand on a plus de 50 ans dans une boîte
il faut le dire et à 62 ans dans les
pays qui ne sont passés à 62 à 65 vous
voyez comme vous rallongez trois ans au
lieu d'être jeté en effet ou la vidéo
après 50 vous êtes jeter à 53 54 bon
vous allez me dire ça règle pas
forcément le problème peut-être mais en
tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est que
vous avez il y a quand même une
augmentation du taux d'emploi et si vous
le lis avec la formation et l'espérance
de vie qui va augmenter vous allez vers
une tendance d'augmenter le taux
d'emploi des des plus de 50 ou des plus
de 55 ans et la question en fait
fondamentale c'est de dire avec cette
réforme on va faire des économies on
aura plus d'argent on a besoin en effet
beaucoup d'argent pour les moins de 25
ans et pour la transition écologique
donc là c'est un choix de société de
dire en effet on décide de peut-être de
faire cette réforme et d'utiliser cet
argent pour financer d'autres dépenses
mais en effet c'est un choix de société
un choix politique Eric Delannoy c'est
quoi votre choix ou est-ce qu'il faut
par exemple prendre une mesure d'âge
puisque c'est un peu simpliste mais
c'est souvent ce qui est mis en avant
prioritairement moi je regrette qu'on
qu'on est réduit le débat sur les
reformes des retraites à une
problématique de paramètres d'âge je le
regrette fondamentalement et absolument
pas ce qui était dans le premier
programme d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 où
on voulait refonder un système de
retraite qui assure une meilleure
mobilité sociale en étant beaucoup plus
lisible et qui permettent aussi une
meilleure justice sociale en écrasant un
petit peu les écarts de retraite
c'est-à-dire les mieux payés touchant
moins et les héros c'est
considérablement le minimum de retraite
donc un système de justice sociale dans
lequel par ailleurs on arrêtait ces
systèmes absolument scandaleux de
d'origine spéciaux sur lequel on
pourrait revenir donc
après c'est effectivement une position
qu'on peut avoir mais en tout cas on
pourrait en point en débattre à Paris
on en reparlera tout à l'heure si vous
voulez bien si si je joue un petit on
fera un petit chapitre si reprend si je
reprends quelques quelques chiffres
intéressants dans les années 70 vous
aviez quatre actifs pour financer un
retraité
aujourd'hui vous avez 1,7 actif pour
financer un autre t en 2050 vous aurez
1,2 actif pour financer un retraité ça
veut dire que vous avez de moins en
moins de cotisants et de plus en plus de
retraités premier élément deuxième
élément la France a le nombre d'années
passées en retraite le plus élevé des
pays de l'OCDE 25 ans c'est-à-dire plus
de 5 ans en moyenne plus élevé que la
moyenne des pays de plus 5 ans avec une
espérance vie qui ne cesse d'augmenter
donc on passe plus de temps en retraite
d'accord donc moi je veux bien qu'on
qu'on fait qu'on aille plus en retraite
en ayant beaucoup de moyens mais comment
on fait pour financer ça deuxième aspect
et je rejoins ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure il y a un vrai problème c'est
que les entreprises veulent plus des
salariés au bout de 55 ans mais en
augmentant le le
[Musique]
l'âge de départ de retraite qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on renverse la charge de la
preuve c'est à dire que quelqu'un une
entreprise qui veut se séparer d'un
collaborateur plutôt doit payer et du
coup il y a une partie du coup qui
devrait être assumée par les entreprises
qui ne veulent plus ses collaborateurs
là donc aussi même en termes de
dynamique économique c'est très simple
de pouvoir augmenter la joue de la
retraite et enfin le dernier point que
je voulais que je voulais ajouter c'est
que on oublie pas parler de l'âge
d'entrer dans l'emploi on parle souvent
de l'âge de sortie mais en 1975 un
emploi stable on l'avait à 20 ans
aujourd'hui on l'a 27 ans d'accord en
moyenne quelqu'un rentre en emploi entre
23 et 24 ans c'est à dire qu'on arrive
plus tard sur le marché de l'emploi et
on ne voudrait pas sortir plus tard il y
a une aberration économique qui fait
qu'on met en place un système dans
lequel on parle plus de temps à
travailler que de ne pas travailler avec
de moins en moins de moyens pour le
financer et ensuite on parle des rues si
on met les choses sur la table faut tout
mettre sur la table or c'est pas le cas
en France parce que il y a toujours des
hypocrisies immenses par exemple il y a
trois paramètres pour réformer les
retraites enfin pour augmenter les
recettes augmenter les cotisations ça
personne n'en parle personne n'en parle
parce qu'on est dans un une logique de
baisse d'impôts et de baisse des
prélèvements sociaux il y a baisser les
pensions c'est-à-dire baisser les
pensions des retraités actuels personne
n'en parle c'est la si c'est un pacte
social on peut dire aussi quel transfert
se joue entre la jeunesse et et les
personnes âgées c'est une question
complètement tabou il y a dans les
sujets tabous prenez on parlait des
expériences de vie oui l'espérance de
vie augmente mais ça dépend des classes
sociales quand vous êtes ouvriers vous
mourrez et beaucoup plus tôt que quand
vous êtes col blanc tranquillement et ça
personne le dit parce que c'est non on
parle un peu de pénibilité à la marge en
fonction de meeting mais on meurt
beaucoup plus jeune quand on a quand on
quand on est ouvrier donc faut le dire
aussi l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
elle est en dessous de 60 ans pour toute
une pour plusieurs cas
on va on va faire une petite un petit
chapitre sur les huiles spéciaux je vous
entends l'un et l'autre Pablo vous dites
que c'est c'est pas un scandale non mais
il y a certains égyptus qui ont un
véritable à tout d'un coup c'est certain
mais non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que les régimes spéciaux en fait sont
des Contis sociaux il y a vous avez
différents branches en situation de
monopole on peut avoir des compter des
comptes des conquêtes dans une situation
en fait quand la société dans un état de
stress comme c'est actuellement ou parce
qu'en fait ce je vais vous parler depuis
tout à l'heure en fait c'est une société
idéale où il y aurait le plein emploi où
les gens serait bien rémunérés etc
sur les cadres pour les cadres pour les
gars
aux alentours de 5% on est aux
situations
on est déjà on est à 7,5 et ensuite vous
avez tous les gens qui sont en fait pas
qu'on se bat pas dans les chiffres du
chômage mais qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
d'emploi on est donc vous dites c'est
qui ce sont non mais ce sont des cons
qui sociaux chaque branche chaque
secteur qui se qui bénéficie d'un régime
spécial en fait ils ont ils ont gagné
des choses moi je pense qu'il aurait
mieux s'aligner en fait sur ces régimes
spéciaux s'en inspirer pas forcément
s'aligner
de Paris tout le monde va pas partir à
40 jeux ans mais qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire avec un danseur de l'Opéra
de Paris vous allez lui dire jusqu'à 65
ans je prends juste le registre spécial
de la RATP les conducteurs partent à 52
ans en moyenne avec une retraite qui est
supérieure de 25% aux autres aux autres
salariés du secteur des transports
privés alors on peut dire que c'est
effectivement des social c'est tout à
fait vrai mais simplement parce que
c'est en situation de monopole et qu'en
situation de monopole on est plus sur
les intérêts catégoriels que sur les
intérêts communs et le problème c'est
qu'il faut revenir sur de l'intérêt
commun et pas sur l'intérêt catégoriel
là c'est vraiment le piège dans lequel
on tombe c'est à dire de mettre en
opposition différentes catégories c'est
surtout pas ça en effet pourquoi il y a
eu ces réunies spéciaux parce que dans
le public souvent vous gagnez moins
pendant votre carrière et donc vous avez
plus d'avantages on va dire sociaux de
partir plus tôt donc des avantages en
nature alors que dans le privé en effet
vous aviez un salaire plus important ce
qui se passe c'est difficile on va dire
la pilule avaler c'est que souvent un
même qualification les salariés du privé
notamment faiblement ou très peu
qualifiant ou beaucoup plus de
précarisation en termes d'emploi en
termes de retraite etc que le même type
de qualité de personnel dans le même
qualification dans le public mais bon
financé c'est un petit peu plus complexe
que ça donc là le le problème c'est que
pour faire passer en effet il y a
vraiment l'idée toujours de faire des
efforts 55 ans donc le prix vous dire
d'accord on est d'accord de financer les
régimes
spéciaux qui sont déficitaires mais de
l'autre côté à ce moment-là vous avez
raison il faut revoir le taux
d'indemnisation avoir des avantages pour
des personnes du secteur publiquement et
le problème c'est que c'est un peu juste
parfois une image qui peut y avoir mais
c'est pas forcément économiquement vrai
de dire les régimes spéciaux un petit
peu cette niche et puis le reste on s'en
fiche et donc pour des personnes qui ont
eu vraiment une paupérisation dans leur
condition de travail et bien il y a
vraiment l'idée de se dire bah moi j'ai
perdu en salaire je me suis fait en
effet virer parce qu'on usine à fermer
et en plus je perds au niveau de la
retraite on termine là-dessus pour ce
premier chapitre on va maintenant parler
du budget le budget 2023 qui a été
présenté ce lundi en conseil des
ministres Jourdain vous pouvez nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau bienvenue Steve
bonsoir quelle est la la philosophie
générale de ce budget protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français c'est
l'idée qui est mise en avant par le
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs le titre
de cette loi de finances 2023 protéger
les Français et aller vers le plein
emploi l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
de lutter contre l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie est plus généralement contre
l'inflation une inflation que Bruno Le
Maire évalue à 6% pour l'année prochaine
écoutez-le
notre prévision est du reste que
l'inflation restera à un niveau élevé
dans les mois qui viennent autour de 6 %
avant de baisser comme nous l'avons
annoncé à plusieurs reprises dans le
courant de l'année 2023 autour de 4%
. dans ce contexte je veux souligner à
quel point l'économie française résiste
elle résiste sur le front de la
croissance qui devrait atteindre 2,7% en
2022 et que nous anticipons positive à
1% en 2023 une prévision de croissance
très très optimiste la Banque de France
tablette sur une croissance de seulement
0,5% le CDE prévoit une croissance de
0,6 en 2023 et de manière générale le
Conseil des finances publiques juge
exagérément optimiste les prévisions du
gouvernement Thomas alors pour lutter
contre l'inflation quelles sont les
principales mesures proposées par le
gouvernement deux grandes mesures ont
été annoncées il y a tout d'abord la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire la
hausse du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité sera limitée l'année
prochaine à 15% au lieu de 120% coût
total de la mesure 45 milliards d'euros
autre mesure pour le pouvoir d'achat
l'indexation sur l'inflation de l'impôt
sur le revenu un mécanisme qui empêchera
notamment que les salariés qui ont
bénéficié de virus de salaire né à payer
plus d'impôts l'année prochaine coup de
cette mesure pour nos finances publiques
6 milliards d'euros et puis alors comme
chaque année lors de la présentation du
budget on a vu fleurir pas mal de
communiquer de municipal et les gagnants
et les perdants voilà on va commencer
avec les perdants ils sont nombreux de 3
le ministère des Anciens Combattants
voit son budget diminuer pour l'année
prochaine moins 200 millions d'euros
c'est aussi le cas de la mission France
2030 qui se voit privé d'un milliard
d'euros il y aura aussi des coupes
budgétaires et des coupes et des
diminutions des effectifs au ministère
de l'Économie et puis du côté des
gagnants le grand vainqueur c'est le
ministère du Travail qui voit son budget
augmenter de 6,7 milliards d'euros
augmentation également pour le ministère
de la transition écologique plus 6,6
milliards d'euros parmi les gagnants il
y a également le ministère de
l'Éducation plus 3,7 milliards le
ministère de la Santé plus 2,1 milliard
d'euros en résumé Thomas peu de dépenses
peu de diminution des dépenses publiques
pour l'année prochaine ça fait des mois
qu'on nous annonce la fin du quoi qu'il
en coûte et bien dans les faits il
continue malgré les annonces du
gouvernement merci Steve effectivement
on écoutera Gabriel Attal dans un
instant alors il y en a qui a pas tout à
fait la même analyse on va on va
l'entendre tout de suite c'est le
présent de la commission des finances à
l'Assemblée le député LFI de
Seine-Saint-Denis Eric Coquerel écoutait
ce qu'il dit du budget deuxième reproche
que je pourrais faire à ce budget il
continue à garder en optique l'idée que
l'impératif c'est quand même que l'état
des pansements qu'il y ait moins de
dépenses publiques
et que on baisse les impôts des
entreprises et de concitoyens les plus
riches c'est-à-dire en gros une
politique de l'offre de la compétitivité
et malgré tout de baisse et dépenses
publiques Pablo Pio Vivien est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord est-ce que c'est un
budget
qui promeut la politique de l'offre on
va dire ça comme ça c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'a dit alors vous avez pas passé
Gabriel Attal mais c'est ce qu'il est
dit
il a bien résumé il a dit on va en gros
les dépenses de l'État vont baisser 0,5%
et ils pensent des 0,4% et les dépenses
des collectivités territoriales vont
baisser de 0,5%. donc il y a quand même
une baisse au final mais j'aimerais
revenir en fait sur ce qui a été dit sur
le bouclier tarifaire enfin le oui le
bouclier qui a été mise en place parce
que en fait ce qui a été dit par Steve
c'est en gros il va y avoir une
augmentation que de 15 % du prix du gaz
et d'électricité en 2023 et pas de 120%
comme ça aurait pu être le cas si en
gros on avait été sur un marché libre ça
reste quand même une augmentation de 15%
je rappelle que le prix du le prix de
l'électricité avait été bloqué il était
bloqué depuis février il avait augmenté
4% février il a pas réaugmenter depuis
et que le prix du gaz était bloqué
depuis octobre 2021 donc là tout d'un
coup vous allez avoir une augmentation
de 15% et je peux dire que les ménages
ils vont le voir sur leur facture de la
même façon le 1er janvier vont s'arrêter
toutes les remises à la pompe enfin pour
l'instant sauf si je ne m'abuse ils
n'ont pas prolongé ce dispositif je suis
d'accord avec vous mais c'est une vraie
question en combien de temps on reste
dans une économie totalement administrée
ou dans combien de temps en fait on
reste dans une économie qui est
complètement qui laisse qui laisse
autant d'importance au fait libre marché
qui qui ne marche pas parce que
aujourd'hui effectivement les prix de
l'énergie
le prix à la fois de l'essence de
l'électricité et du gaz on ne peut pas
en fait on ne peut pas les assumer à
l'échelle admis à l'échelle individuelle
ni à l'échelle collective donc en fait
il faut se poser la question peut-être
qu'il faut revoir totalement totalement
la façon dont à la fois on on
s'improvisions dans l'électricité la
façon dont ensuite on répartissa sur le
territoire mais enfin vous êtes bien
d'accord je suis d'accord que ça fait
une une
subventionne largement secteur
énergétique je suis complètement
d'accord c'est vraiment super fusion de
l'argent de l'État que Total arrive à
mettre le prix à la pompe à ce niveau là
afin que toutes les mais en même temps
si vous ne faites pas ça ben vous êtes
genre c'est les prix du marché mondiaux
et là je peux vous dire le prix du baril
moi je sais pas pourquoi enfin j'ai
entendu Bruno Le Maire en parler il dit
oui vous allez voir le prix du baril ça
va peut-être genre redescendre on en
sait absolument rien et ok
alors rebondis montre du baril est
corrélés au prix du PIB à l'évolution du
PIB donc si vous avez une littérature
qui existe qui montre qu'il y a une
véritable corrélation
il est en train de baisser donc
justement le prix du baril est en train
de baisser pourquoi parce que quand vous
avez un ralentissement de la croissance
mondiale forcément votre baril
s'effondre d'ailleurs
- 30 % de la demande d'ailleurs
il faut je rebondis ce que c'est
intéressant sur le décalage entre des
mesures politiques et et le marché c'est
à partir du moment où on rentre dans
cette logique et j'entends l'argument de
dire qu'il y a des millions de Français
qui sont en grande difficulté financière
aujourd'hui mais la difficulté c'est que
le politique prend une mesure par
exemple sur le le prix à la pompe et
puis finalement au moment où la mesure
est la plus efficace bah le le prix du
baril est en train de baisser quoi par
rapport à ça on peut pas vous dire que
bah justement on est dans une économie
complètement administrée c'est parce
qu'on n'est pas dans les lois du marché
marché qu'on va pas payer ça donc là on
y est donc déjà il faut pas laisser le
marché faire c'est exactement ce qu'on
fait dans cette proportion vous regardez
les taux d'inflation dans les autres
pays en Europe au Pays-Bas dans les pays
balles en Allemagne c'est le double donc
il faut quand même avoir conscience des
choses en France avec ses êtres là vous
avez quand même une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat augmenter de 2 % 2021 là qui
devrait baisser de 0,6% donc certes on
est dans une baisse qu'on avait une
augmentation de croissance grâce au quoi
qu'il en coûte donc il faut quand même
relativiser et surtout comparer par
rapport aux autres donc on est vraiment
dans une économie complètement
administrée le coup c'est quand même 45
milliards d'euros donc c'est pas un coup
qui est négligeable et cet argent ça
veut dire qu'on va pas l'utiliser à
autre chose donc ça c'est quand même
aussi un problème un rapport juste pour
finir par rapport au pack quand on dit
le prix du pétrole va baisser etc c'est
sûr qu'on regarde pour l'inflation ce
qu'on appelle le mix énergétique donc là
la problématique c'est pas du tout
est-ce qu'on est dépendant en effet de
l'énergie extérieure etc le problème
c'est qu'on a pas du tout diversifié
notre mix en Europe comme on fait les
autres pays donc c'est ça qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir eu aucune
vision européenne sur les politiques
énergétiques donc une fois que l'on a
dit ça ce qu'il faut quand même savoir
économiquement c'est que avec ce que
vous dites ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
relocaliser utilisez moins l'électricité
etc ça va vers la transition écologique
mais c'est un coup clairement
inflationniste sur le coup des biens et
des services donc là il faut quand même
le dire concrètement on aura une
inflation qui va durer je vais vous
donner la parole tout de suite terrique
de la noix mais on écoute on l'avait
évoqué le ministre chargé des comptes
publics Gabriel Attal oui il dit donc
c'est un budget de protection écoutez ce
budget est aussi un budget de protection
de nos comptes publics nous sommes
sortis du quoi qu'il en coûte et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire déjà que nous étions
passés au combien ça coûte ça veut dire
quoi c'est là que nous avons un cadre 5%
de déficit à ne pas dépasser l'an
prochain je rappelle que nous avons
réduit le déficit public ces dernières
années il était près de 9% en 2020 6,4%
en 2021 il est de 5% cette année il sera
à nouveau de 5% l'an prochain nous
agissons avec un cadre protéger nos
finances publiques ça veut dire que
toute dépense doit être évaluée un euro
dépensé est un euro raisonné est un euro
évalué est un euro immédiatement utile à
la protection des Français
Eric Delannoy ce budget on aura
peut-être du presque commencé par là il
repose sur une prévision de croissance
de 1% l'an prochain et on l'a vu grâce à
Steve jandra c'est sans doute optimiste
voire très optimiste il faut on va voir
ressortir les critiques budget à
sincères on entend ça à peu près chaque
année oui chaque année donc il faut bien
prendre des hypothèses on est parti
d'une croissance qui était assise et
demi en sortant du covid il est
maintenant 2,5 c'est vrai que ça décroît
en fait la vérité c'est qu'on ne sait
pas du tout vers quoi ça va aller donc
il faut bien prendre une hypothèse et la
figer à partir du moment où on constate
aujourd'hui finalement les entreprises
vont très bien il faut le savoir que les
records les bénéfices sont jamais été
aussi importants et que donc il y a
matière à investissement et il faut
éviter de casser les anti les
anticipations et le et le convoyage le
bien-être des entrepreneurs en évitant
d'être dans un catastrophisme
insupportable donc on est sur un budget
que moi je qualifie d'équilibriste en
fait parce que des injonctions
contradictoires une somme d'injonction
contradictoire où on veut protéger les
Français ça revient tout de suite enfin
tout le temps alors moi je déteste cette
dialectique de protéger les Français
d'ailleurs l'État n'est pas là pour les
Français la protection c'est des
responsabiliser des responsabilisants à
mourir ce qu'il faut c'est protéger les
plus fragiles et augmenter les capacités
d'agir des autres ça devrait être ça le
l'objectif de cibler en fait il faut
cibler en fait on ne cible pas beaucoup
il y a une dialectique du ciblage qui
avait été qui avait été mise en place
qu'on entend plus d'ailleurs dans la
dialectique d'aujourd'hui qui pourtant
était importante alors il est vrai que
Bercy a travaillé sur le ciblage et que
c'est une véritable usine à gaz par
exemple pour les par exemple pour le le
coup de le coup de l'essence comme les
carburant comment on fait pour ce savoir
que quelqu'un qui va à la pompe mérite
d'avoir un prix plus faible ou plus
important donc il y a une difficulté
technique qui fait que le ciblage est
compliqué on aurait pu néanmoins laisser
dériver les coûts de l'énergie et
augmenter considérablement chaque
énergie le seul problème c'est qu'en
faisant ça c'est très impopulaire parce
que ça donne le sentiment d'un
assistanat il y en a encore les procès
stupides autour de mes si on donne de
l'argent au ménage ça va pas être fait
pour ce pourquoi c'était c'était c'était
fait etc donc ils ont préféré attendez
juste pour bien comprendre il fallait
laisser filer les enfin les prix de
l'énergie et aider ceux qui en avait
vraiment besoin avec le chèque énergie
c'est ça en boostant le chèque énergie
et on boostant de manière à avoir une
véritable offre ciblée positive et non
pas finalement quelque chose qui va vers
tout le monde parce que finalement enfin
moi il y a un point sur lequel je ne
peux pas être en désaccord avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour une fois ainsi que
aujourd'hui les fonctionnements du
marché sont terrifiants sur le marché de
l'énergie faut savoir que sur l'ensemble
des contrats qui sont passés par les
brokers en énergie moins de 5% de ces
contrats là donne lieu à une livraison
physique d'énergie le reste c'est des
échanges de la spéculation de la
spéculation alors moi je ne condamne pas
la spéculation dans ce cas là de gestion
de la liquidité pour permettre de faire
en sorte que les approvisionneurs et
ceux qui vendent puissent se servir en
temps réel c'est très important la
spéculation quand elle est encadrée et
on pourrait l'encadrer sauf que personne
ne s'y ne s'y met pourquoi personne ne
s'y met parce que ça ne dépend pas de
l'Europe la plupart des brokers sont aux
États-Unis que les États-Unis en fait
dans la situation actuelle se enfin il
gagne beaucoup d'argent ils vont leur
gaz de schiste ils vont leur pétrole de
schiste tout va bien pour les Américains
c'est l'Europe qui souffre et on a aucun
moyen de limiter la spéculation qui à
mon avis et là c'est une spéculation
personnelle compte pour à peu près 90%
de la hausse des prix de l'énergie
aujourd'hui voilà le problème il est là
et on a aucun moyen de réguler ça parce
que c'est le fonctionnement du marché et
on a beau dire surtout les tons y
compris en beuglant comme certains
peuvent le faire que il faudrait changer
les règles de la spéculation bah je suis
désolé enfin aller dire ça Biden et le
dire ce broker faite de la régulation
mondiale quand on n'a pas été l'Europe a
pas le pouvoir de reprendre ça mais non
on n'a aucun pouvoir la France associe
de particulier qu'on a une quasi
autonomie énergétique par rapport aux
autres pays grâce au nucléaire qui a été
démantelé dans ces 30 dernières années
et qu'on a du mal à remettre en place
d'accord on en a fait un vraiment un
gâchis considérable par rapport à des
lobbies écologiques qui n'ont pas vu
l'aspect systémique de la cause de la
chose mais aujourd'hui
l'Espagne c'est très bien débrouillé en
développement le renouvelable les
Allemands ont totalement foiré leur
politique et énergétique et nous on n'a
pas vu qu'on avait un trésor dans les
mains qu'on n'a pas entretenu qui
s'appelle le nucléaire ce qui nous
aurait considérablement aidé dans la
gestion en ce moment ça devrait être
l'âge d'or du nucléaire français et on
devrait apprendre
à 15 ans un dernier mot sur sur le
budget Anne-Sophie alcif parce qu'on a
assez peu employé le terme de récession
or c'est quand même c'est quand même
peut-être ça l'obsession du gouvernement
avec ce budget alors évitez la récession
tout à fait normalement pas en France
parce qu'on dit on est à 1% par rapport
à la Banque de France - 0,5 + 1 % c'est
un un échelle enfin une fourchette donc
là aussi c'est vrai quand on fait de la
prévision en fourchette c'est plus
facile donc il y a un risque de
récession pourquoi parce que l'Allemagne
est dans une situation très compliquée
là il y a vraiment un risque de rester
sur fort en Allemagne le Royaume-Uni
n'en parlons pas donc c'est vrai que
deux grandes économies en Europe en
récession ça peut vraiment avoir un
impact
mais c'est vrai que là aussi contient on
va dire un peu mieux et vous dites tout
va bien aux Etats-Unis non quand même
tout ne va pas bien aux États-Unis aussi
quand on parle de risques de récession
c'est quand même plus chez eux ou donc
là bien évidemment sera un impact
mondial donc oui il y a ce risque après
le risque est à nuancer c'est vraiment
au niveau c'est pas le même problème le
vrai le vrai sujet c'est les politiques
monétaires on voit qu'on a des hausses
des taux et le sujet c'est est-ce que ça
va pouvoir juguler l'inflation tant en
Europe qu'aux États-Unis oui ou non
comme on est resté pendant 10 ans dans
des taux très très bas et bien
aujourd'hui une interrogation de se dire
est-ce que c'est banque centrales sont
encore assez solides pour pouvoir avoir
un effet un impact sur l'inflation et là
si la crédibilité entamée et qui a pas
vraiment d'impact c'est là où il y aura
vraiment un risque de récession allez le
dernier thème de notre débat d'actualité
c'est la démission de Julien Bayou de
son poste de secrétaire national du
Parti Europe Écologie Les Verts il l'a
annoncé par communiqué ce matin je vous
en dis un extrait vous le savez
peut-être je suis accusé de fait qui ne
me sont pas présentés dans mes
accusateurs et accusatrices disent
qu'ils ne sont pas pén répréhensible et
dont je ne peux pour autant pas me
défendre puisqu'on refuse de m'entendre
ces Kafka à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
voilà ce que dit Julien Bayou et son
avocate Marie doser a donné une
conférence de presse cet après-midi on
en écoute un extrait
du juste combat contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes à des fins
politiques
personne n'ignore que le Congrès des
écologistes se tient en fin d'année
l'ambition politicienne ne saurait
justifier toutes les croisades
la vie privée ne peut être rendue
publique que si elle recèle des
comportements pénalement sanctionnés
sauf à prendre le risque de sombrer dans
l'arbitraire or c'est précisément cette
barrière qui vient d'être franchie avec
une désinvolture au bas mot inquiétant
cette rupture entre Julien Bayou et son
ancienne compagne pourrait sans doute en
tout cas c'est mon avis du rester
d'ordre privée mais elle pose une vraie
question Mathieu celle de ces cellules
d'écoute sur les violences sexuelles et
sexistes qui ont été mises en place dans
les partis politiques oui parce qu'on
peut se demander au fond quelle est leur
efficacité on sait qu'elles étaient
destinées à recueillir notamment la
parole des femmes à éviter que ne
s'instaure des systèmes de violence
sexuelles ou sexistes ou plutôt comme on
dit maintenant des violences systémiques
ce qui revient en même pourquoi parce
que les partis politiques sont des
organisations qui favorisent l'emprise
qui favorise le culte du chef qui
favorise l'omerta bref tout ça fait un
terrain quand même assez propice
plusieurs parties c'était donc dotées de
cellules internes Europe Écologie les
vers les premiers dans le sillage de
l'affaire Baupin le PS le Parti
communiste LFI on notera au passage que
tous les scandales qui déchirent
aujourd'hui ces mouvements ont surgit à
gauche et pour cause seule la gauche
c'est noté de pareil structures dans les
autres mouvements de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique c'est toujours
circuler il y a rien à voir et le
problème c'est que ces cellules
inspirées par une scène réaction je le
redis et portée par des féministes bien
décidés à bouger les choses n'a pas
encore je trouve à mes yeux en tout cas
fait la preuve de son efficacité ou en
tout cas pas dans les affaires qui ont
fait irruption dans le débat public on
rappelle qu'avant que les projecteurs ne
se braquent sur les écolos pas moins de
4 personnalités de la France insoumise
et non des moindres ont été mis en cours
et que d'autres n'ont circule et tout ça
en 5 mois de temps seulement alors
qu'est-ce qui ne fonctionne pas selon
vous alors à mes yeux d'abord la lenteur
elles avaient été conçues ces cellules
pour pallier notamment les défaillances
de la justice qui met trop de temps à se
prononcer et puis le défaillance de la
Justice a appréhender le phénomène des
violences sexuelles et sexistes et
notamment voilà à cause des délais je
disais or les cellules ne paraissent pas
tellement plus rapides à se prononcer
quand on demande un avis on a des élus
qui sont suspendus
qui se mettent en retrait on sait pas
pour combien de temps donc il y a un
problème de lenteur et un problème
d'opacité ensuite pour des raisons qui
sont bien compréhensibles celles des
femmes qui ne veulent pas témoigner
visage découvert des violences qu'elles
ont subies donc ça c'est très bien mais
pour des raisons parfois moins à voir
aussi comme la tentation de laver son
linge sale en famille à l'abri des
regards il y a aussi un problème à mon
avis d'indépendance elles ont été
imaginées par les parties ces cellules
parfois présidées par des élus des élus
sièges elle n'échappe pas aujourd'hui ni
aux soupçon de protection des camarades
ou à l'inverse et on le voit ici dans
l'extrait que vous avez passé ni au
soupçon de règlement de compte interne
ou de positionnement politique et puis
les méthodes posent aussi question ces
Kafka à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
disaient Julien Bayou que vous avez cité
serait qu'une ne se connaît pas les
faits l'effet qu'on lui reproche ça me
fait penser en mai dernier à table ou à
cet effet mer candidat de la France
insoumise qui s'était fait écarter de
liste sans qu'on lui ait jamais précisé
de quoi il était accusé ni par qui ni où
ni quand ni comment alors des députés
insoumises ont reconnu la semaine
dernière qu'elles avancées parfois à
tâtons sur ces questions complexes et je
trouve que cela se sent et si on cherche
des solutions comment améliorer certains
imaginent confiés ces affaires une haute
autorité indépendante un peu comme sur
le le modèle de ce qu'il existe pour la
transparence de la vie publique
c'est-à-dire les finances et l'argent
des élus alors c'est une piste d'autres
réclament un minimax et cellules
composées de bénévoles il faut le
rappeler aussi parce que ce sont des
bénévoles donc c'est pour ça aussi que
les délais sont parfois très longs
travaillent plus rapidement on retrouve
quand même une forme d'équilibre entre
le recueil de la parole des femmes qui
est nécessaire et la présomption
d'innocence mais surtout ça se règle des
procédures contradictoires et c'est ça
qui est un peu délirant parce que moi
j'ai regardé quand même les statuts de
la cellule de Coupe d'Europe Écologie
l'hiver normalement le contradictoire
est prévu et la personne qui est mise en
cause doit pouvoir avoir connaissance du
dossier donc tout ça c'est très long en
fait je veux dire une bêtise mais chose
on serait trop conseillé de de au parti
politique de confier ses affaires le
plus tôt possible et le mieux possible à
la justice plutôt que de tenter de jouer
les justiciers dans des organisations
qui restent militantes car même si la
justice reste imparfaite c'est quand
même ce qu'on a trouvé mieux pour faire
le job alors on va je vous donne la
parole à l'un et l'autre avoir votre à
votre avis pour info on va longuement
demain à débattre autour de
l'exemplarité en politique avec nos
partenaires de doxa qui publient leur
baromètre donc voilà c'est pour ça que
dans ce débat on y consacre relativement
peu de temps mais quand même je voudrais
vous entendre
Eric Delannoy je commence avec vous
tiens qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire la
démission de Julien Bayou bon moi je la
trouve extrêmement triste je porte pas
je viens bahut dans mon cœur
particulièrement mais ce qu'il subit
aujourd'hui et le symptôme effectivement
d'un d'un vrai problème ou en gros il y
a une vision très robespiriste de la
justice quand même pas par les parties
donc moi je suis d'accord moi je je
refuse de dire que on met des cellules
de soi-disant de justice parallèle sous
prétexte que la justice est trop lente
la justice sur des affaires comme ça
comme sur toutes les affaires a besoin
de son temps et je parle pas là de des
problématiques de moyens mais a besoin
de son temps pour se faire une idée et
pour pouvoir instruire ce n'est pas aux
réseaux sociaux à faire la justice et à
soumettre quiconque à la vanille te
populaire donc au même titre que je
considère que ces cellules sont avant
tout des espèces de de comment dirais-je
des de pureté pour pour pour
des formes de secte autant autant je
considère que il faut confier le plus
vite possible les ce type d'affaires la
justice point enfin je veux dire c'est
de mon point de vue ça ne se discute pas
tout le reste c'est contre-productif on
fait de la justice parallèle on est dans
on est jugé par qui et donc c'est ça ne
fait que des débats sont que des débats
sont fins Pablo Pio Vivien il faut
peut-être remonter au point de départ de
de ce qui est aboutit aujourd'hui CR7
démission de Gien Bayou c'est Sandrine
Rousseau sur le plateau de de c'est à
vous sur France 5 qui raconte qu'elle a
entendu l'ex-compagne Julien Bay tout
part de là où tout repart de là parce
que je viens Bayou lui-même avait dit il
y a eu il y a une enquête interne et
elle voulait laisser il voulait laisser
le temps cette enquête en terme de
d'avancer il y a quand même est-ce que
finalement comment je peux vous poser
cette question est-ce que Sandrine
Rousseau est-elle pas en train de faire
du mal à la cause qu'elle veut défendre
avec cette histoire là ce qu'a fait
Sandrine Rousseau c'est que elle a pris
de cours
de la cellule des violences sexistes et
sexuelles d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
qui avaient été saisis je crois en genre
en juin ou en juillet et qui allait
auditionner en fait l'ex-compagne le
sentiment d'être dans la la manipulation
confrontés à la fois à laquelle il
confondait à la fois la justice mais
aussi ses cellules de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes c'est
pas que la justice est trop lente la
justice avait pas enfin elle est aussi
trop lente mais surtout elle n'arrive
pas à se positionner sur les questions
mais je sais même pas si elle doit
pouvoir le faire parce que le problème
c'est que lorsque vous avez des
violences sexuelles et ces sessionnaires
qui sont caractérisés il y a aucun
problème si une femme arrive avec des
Bleus etc plusieurs fois évidemment il
faut que la justice puisse dire le
coupable c'est le mari ou c'est le
conjoint et cetera mais le problème
c'est que lorsque c'est des problèmes de
consentement c'est à dire que en gros
vous avez une femme qui qui va voir par
exemple la police ou qui va voir la
cellule de
de lutte contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelle et qui dit bah voilà moi
j'ai été abusé j'ai pas donné mon
consentement alors qu'il y a eu un acte
sexuel et ça se passe dans un lit dans
une chambre préférée etc comment vous
voulez que l'État à travers la justice
son bras armée de justice ou la police
elle vérifié qu'il y ait bien
consentement plus la cellule interne
d'un parti politique et en fait ils sont
exactement
qui aboutissent le plus souvent à
classer ah oui mais c'est ça aussi
problème
alors ça progresse mais moi je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus que l'État genre
mettre une caméra dans toutes les
chambres à coucher de France c'est pas
ça non plus l'objectif non mais donc bah
oui mais parfois il y a que ça en fait
qui pourrait dire que effectivement une
femme n'a pas donné son consentement
lors d'un acte sexuel et le problème
exactement d'animaux parce que je pense
que tout ça c'est un problème en fait de
philosophie c'est que moi je pense que
ce qu'il faut faire avancer le plus
c'est les questions du féminisme mais au
sens philosophique et de pratique le
féminisme c'est pas juste un mot clé en
fait que peuvent utiliser les différents
partis politiques comme un espèce de
totem qu'ils agitent à chaque fois en
disant oui en écologie les Verts c'est
écologique c'est une pardon c'est
écologiste mais c'est aussi féministe
elle est fille on est féministe etc
c'est une pratique en fait au quotidien
il y a des philosophes qui l'ont qui
l'ont pensé il y a des femmes qui se
sont battues pendant des dizaines
d'années et c'est ça à mon avis avant
que d'essayer de savoir où est le droit
ou est-ce qu'on fait à quel moment faire
rentrer le droit etc ou c'est des
questions qui sont excessivement
compliquées je pense que c'est d'abord
en fait sur la philosophie et sur les
pratiques il faut travailler merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat d'actualité